We did it!
We finally did it!
We broke the world record!
*LWAIY INTRO*
Pewds livestream of fortnite has 100,000 more live viewers than all of fortnite on twitch right now making him the biggest fortnite streamer
YES!
Let this be an inspirational message for all of you
The biggest fortnite streamer
I can use this to every brand I've ever worked with
"Hey, you know, biggest fortnite streamer"
FORTNITE! I'm the greatest fortnite streamer
Let it be known
okay great
I have a feeling its mostly gonna be Elon Musk memes
DAMN! I gotta say though
I'm more of a colonizing mars guy. Damn
That colonizing mars girl looks hot
There we go everyone
This is what we need to show people
Once Elon Musk hosts meme review...
...Everyone has to buy a Tesla, alright?
you understand?
I!
oh god it keeps going! what the?
*video* T-Series, go home!
Elon musk hosts meme review at last
*its time for youtube's favorite show everybody, meme review!*
*that's right. welcome.*
*I'm...*
Those dead eyes
*who am I?*
alright, I've seen this one. I sent it to Brad
He was very thrilled about it
What do you mean Brad?
What... what the frick is that supposed to mean?  (your language sounds like it comes from a mumble rap community)
This is what I'm talking about
At this point, we have 83 million
subscribers
We need to branch out
We need to go to places unknown before
*Listen*
*I didn't want to do this but*
*I gotta tell you*
*PewDiePie has closed captions on all his videos*
*So the deaf community can watch*
(Bitch Lasagna Plays)
That's true actually
Ay!
I'm so confused. What is happening?
Is this real? Does that work?
I don't know anything about sign language
I know that one
That's pretty cool though. Thank you very much RoseLBad (good job pewds)
For doing your part
*Dr Phil time Dr Phil time*
oh god stop
*everybody get pumped its dr phil time. send them to the ranch! I think I need help. Send me to the ranch!*
*this episode is sponsored by g fuel*
wow! dr. phil got a g fuel sponsorship!
*70 million!*
*whats good! t-series go home!*
*its time for youtube's favorite show everybody. meme review*
ugh it makes me so uncomfortable
*I'm dr. phil*
oh god it keeps going!
*its me everybody. and today we're gonna play pokemon stadium*
oh my god! *felix set it up for us*
*and I'm really looking forward to playing this. we haven't played it in awhile.*
*in Spanish*
*I don't know why I have it in Spanish*
*this game gets very intense*
*yeah. should we make it more diificult for each other?*
*like how about I preselect your 6 pokemon*
That's the best thing ive ever seen
*It's me everybody*
well done
that is horrifying
what! whos not 9?
who's actually not 9?
huh?
I know youre out there
show yourself goddammit
just kidding, he will definitely come on
suicide rate jump to 100 okay
did you guys actually see it live?
so I didn't understand what this was about
but apparently there was a petition for spongebob
look at that. 1.2 million people signed it to have sweet victory performed at the superbowl
and they started off making it seem like it was going to happen
but instead they just cut to f**king Travis Scott
that would've been so epic
f**king companies cant get anything right
you put it right in front of them, right in front of their faces going like "hey, theres a brilliant idea just take it. just go with it"
"that's all you gotta do"
"i see what youre doing here but uh,"
"we're gonna have maroon 5 instead"
"people love maroon 5 right?"
well, you did it boy or girl. i don't know
that's pretty goddamn epic
is he 9? is barron trump 9?
ah f**k, alright.  well, we tried
well we know it didn't happen
okay, yeah, yeah. yeah  so this is what happened
you guys should check out MrBeast's video
so apparently they tried- i knew about this. he told me.
but uh, they were gonna try to get blankets in because youre not allowed to obstruct the view
but they took them away
but instead they figured out they could just wear the t shirts
i thought it was brilliant
like the photo that came out of it is so legendary
seriously. even my mom wrote me about it guys
like this was posted by espn
how cool is that
Mr.Beast at this point is just doing his part 100 times over
this is what I'm talking about
we never stop!
We never surrender!
woah, how the frick did you do that? that looks so accurate!
it has to be weird to have a t shirt that says
you know what? Mr. Beast deserves (to host meme review). I agree, okay.
I would love to. I love spicy food.
But I also hate traveling
So there you go. There's a dilemma.
oh damn
Elon-san
Let's make this happen
Let's make everyone of these teslas
automatically subscribe to pewdiepie
what a great idea
NO!
Zee TV, another Indian channel
I think
Look how they massacred my boy
MARKIPLIER HAS FALLEN!
This is what I'm talk- SONY MUSIC INDIA
JACKSEPTICEYE HAS FALLEN!
We're losing the fight
They're picking up all our generals
What's next they'll come for Mr.Beast
I thought it was super dope
This is the problem when you hype stuff up
People are just gonna get disappointed
What? You actually expected him to buy a 5 million dollar superbowl ad?
Like are you kidding me?
"oh he didn't spend 5 million dollars boohoo"
Like Jesus Christ dude
Beautiful
I like how you can barely see it
Amazing. Well done lads
Well done
of course
I'll have a chat with the department
Goddammit! Were we actually that far ahead?
AHH! KEEP SUBSCRIBING!
Oh no, they figured out. They're holding me accountable for what I say again
Clean shaven as well
Oh how the mighty has fallen
What did it cost?
Everything
everything
Well that's just sad
Everyone picked themselves. Well here we are
Listen, desperate times call for desperate measurements
I did what I had to do and I'm not proud of it goddammit
What is this? Can the princess Pewdiepie defeat T-Series
(Were you poisoned?)
Oh I definitely was, I was f**king horrible
Thank you guys. I've been saying this literally for years
One person has signed it. That's it Jablinski. You gotta do it. I'm sorry.
Goddammit
Guys don't tell her that
come on
There it is. Modern problems, modern solutions
Guys do you not understand?
Fortnite is a family friendly game-
If I'm the biggest family friendly youtuber,
fortnite streamer,
This changes the game, alright?
Is the whole thing?
Who's the sub-bot?
Well done
My fellow 9 year olds
Thank you very much
I'm right there with you guys
I understand
But in Sweden we say
[In Swedish] "The one who waits for soMETHING GOOD
waits never... always too long."
I don't know the expression actually but you know what I'm saying
right?
You understand
There you go. #1 on trending. Oopsie how did that happen? Wow
Damn that looks legit
Zero deaths
So far from T-Series at least
I like it too. art_by_zelma very nice. Thank you very much
GUYS WE NEED TO- I never said this but it is time!
T-Series is getting too close, huh?
It's time to play-
Don't get jealous now Youtube (Alinitiepie?)
Don't get jealous and demonetize the video
Oh my god
What the hell?
It actually looks like me
Okay
Oh my god, okay
Thank you everyone for doing their part
These are dark times
But if we keep working together, we can pull through
Maybe at some point, T-Series will just give up
That's pretty much our only strategy
If we hang on long enough, maybe they'll just give up and delete their channel and realize
That's the idea
Let's hope it works out
That's it from me for now
Thank you guys so much for all the love and support
Honestly, it means so much to me
Thank you and as- that was way too lame okay uh
I don't like you guys, alright? There you go
YOU WANT PYRAMIDS?
WE GOT EM!
OH YOU'RE INTO CASTLES, HUH?
WE GOT YOU COVERED, BABY!
YOU WANT SOME PETS?
EASY!
WE GOT IT ALL!
THIS GAME IS STILL RELEVANT GODDAMMIT!
Subscribe to PewDiePie